foreign
hey everybody what's going on Happy New
Year it's 20 [ __ ] 23. it's ridiculous
20 [ __ ] 20. I know it's ridiculous
how it's How one year just happens after
the other one like that
it needs to knock it off
[ __ ] just keeps coming I know right you
never you never get a break from it well
I hope everybody had a good uh New
Year's Eve we actually had a really good
time
yeah had fun tired I'm still tired I'm
tired yeah I'm tired too and we didn't
even like drink all that much I mean we
drank some but we didn't get like super
[ __ ] up no some people did though
a lot of our friends not us
yeah very very funny people holding them
to keep them standing up but it was the
girls mostly but everyone was in a good
mood though it wasn't nobody got like uh
so drunk that it was like a bad time
everybody was just like flapping around
on the dance floor and stuff it was
pretty funny yep
got to make some more tea huh yes we're
almost out of iced tea yeah we're not
drinking we're not drinking any alcohol
today I'll make uh make some tea when
the show's over okay I got that ham
already cooked down there too if you
want some more ham and a ham sandwich or
something yeah I wouldn't mind a hand I
got all them damn split peas I need to
go make some split pea soup out of the
ham I've got ham bones and everything
well yeah I mean you're probably too
tired to do that yeah
Tom Sykes says just as good suggestion
for a haunting episode The Ghost Soldier
uh and only to critique the [ __ ] out of
it for being a lame boring and promptly
made-up episode it's the worst episode I
think it might be I think it might be I
mean I don't know which one we're gonna
do because I usually like to do ones
that are you know kind of entertaining
at least but I don't know we'll see
ghost soldiers is the the most boring of
the older series of the original series
that's true it was yeah
although you know although there's a few
out there they're [ __ ] boring but
yeah Ghost Soldier is like not one of my
favorite ones yeah me neither I always
kind of dreaded that one when that one
came on I was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] here's this one again
um the photograph of the dude yeah
yeah Tom Sykes said uh weakest episode
in season one to four yeah
Mega says uh still recovering from last
night think I'm still drunk wow okay
that's that's pretty good yep I mean we
didn't get home until probably like 3 30
I guess well we went to bed at like 3 30
I think and then I woke up at seven
but I at least I fell back to sleep for
like an hour or two so that was nice uh
slasher Fred says I love movies with
stop-motion animation I do as well and
honestly if you are into I mean at all
into the art form of stop-motion
animation then you really gotta see
Jason in the Argonauts because I feel
like well and I think that Ray
harryhausen himself said that this was
his best work and his favorite movie
that he had done because you have to
think that this prior to this movie he
had kind of done more like B movies you
know what I mean like did he do like um
like beasts from fifty thousand twenty
thousand fathoms how many fathoms was it
yeah bees from some amount of fats
like you know which was black and white
it's a lizard that came out of the water
right yeah yeah and so um so I feel like
Jason and the Argonauts was kind of like
his big like his first kind of big
A-list movie that he worked on
and the thing about it is that I was
watching another review of this and they
said the poor guy that directed this
whose name is Don Chaffee by the way
um you feel like he probably never gets
any credit for directing this movie
because anytime anybody says Jason and
the Argonauts all anybody thinks of is
Ray harryhausen yeah you know I mean he
was a producer on it but he didn't
direct it and
um the monsters that he made like kind
of you know like he had a lot of input
about the script and things like that
because you know they they were kind of
like playing to his strengths you know
like one scene to another
this one had the famous scene where
Jason fights all the damn skeletons yeah
I mean that's easily the best there's a
lot of really cool
um you know scenes in this
um and the skeletons I think still look
amazing because you have to think of how
I mean it's stop motion and Ray
harryhausen I don't really think he had
a crew or didn't really have a big
substantial crew like he would usually
do most that [ __ ] himself and to keep
track because how many skeletons was
there there was I think there was seven
of them and to keep track of like all
the movements of like where they all
were like in space because you had to
move like each one because they're all
moving at the same time yeah and then
there's live action actors that had to
match up with all that how they did that
I saw a thing about how they did that
because I'm sitting there going how the
[ __ ] did they like match that up so
seamlessly what they did was they shot
all the live action [ __ ] first and then
um Ray harryhausen would have would
project the live stuff like on a little
screen like behind his
um his little thing where he was working
with puppets yeah yeah and then so then
he could like put them like in the frame
you know what I mean so they'd be in the
right spot that's why it looks so
seamless but like I said it took forever
they said second four months yeah I
think I don't know if that was just to
do the skeleton fight or to do like all
of the stop motion
for me personally I like to send bad
flicks that he did yeah yeah I like
those better than than Jason uh and uh
[ __ ] clash of the tides the Greek
ones although the great the Greek
stories do have their own charm there
they they and they have their own thing
going on but I preferred the Sinbad ones
there's something about the damn Persian
sea captain and going to the damn
islands and monsters and you know and
and yeah there is some um
there is some traditional monsters in
there uh but there's something about uh
in the Sinbad stories they kind of had a
free hand by mixing cultures in there
you know like he's because he's not he's
traveling from one land to the next so
Sinbad fights you know
Indian goddess stat got a statue with
lots of arms yeah and you know [ __ ]
Persian Sorcerers and
so it's more of a variety as well
variety of stuff yeah hot chicks dressed
like [ __ ] Genie from [ __ ] I Dream
of Jeannie in there if I can get shrunk
down a little small and you have them in
a cage and try to restore it a normal
size and there's just a lot of good
ideas stuff that really
was kind of a little bit for to me as a
kid I saw them in the theater they
seemed more exotic to me than the Greek
stuff well yeah the Greek stuff seemed
more familiar to me because that's kind
of like what you saw at the Museum you
know [ __ ] Museum of national natural
history down in Los Angeles you know a
mom used to take me to that [ __ ] when I
was a little kid and you know the motif
there was all Greek stuff
so I could I kind of it just seemed more
familiar to me for some reason uh the
the Sinbad ones were closer to like
seeing a Star Wars movie for me yeah you
know and really Star Wars is another
British movie that was kind of like made
by the same dudes that did those Sinbad
movies they're kind of a different
evolution of them
but if you've ever seen Clash of the
Titans this is the this is basically the
first episode of The Clash of the Titans
it's you could put the side by side I
was kind of wondering the one scene
where Jason fights the Hydra
to get the Golden Fleece which is
actually not they did change some [ __ ]
from like the original myth
um in the I think in the original myth
it wasn't the Hydra that was guarding
the fleece it was just like a just a
regular Dragon you know it's one of the
regular drivers like you see every day
um you know what I mean but I was
wondering when I was seeing the
animation on the Hydra like the back end
of it looked very much like the back end
like the bottom half of Medusa from
Clash of the Titans from 1981 and I
wondered if he had reused
um some of the pieces which it looked
like it looked like the dab it did look
like freaking um uh
uh same body it did what's her name
again you just said Medusa I'm Medusa's
bite it looked like yeah it was like the
bottom half of a snake like all the
scales and stuff so I was wondering or I
mean maybe he just used the same
materials because there was like almost
20 years like in between these two
movies but I still had some casts left
over that's what I was thinking because
it did look very very similar
but yeah so the thing about this movie I
kind of feel like since came out in 1963
and like I said the director's name was
Don Chaffee who he did some movies like
I think he went like in the 80s he went
and did more like TV but I was actually
surprised to find out that he had
directed Pete's Dragon the one from
1977. do you remember that one uh
vaguely holy [ __ ] that was a cartoon
wouldn't it
um it was live action with a cartoon
dragon so it was a combination it's
funny because my when I was a kid um you
know my parents ran a daycare and Pete's
Dragon and Wizard of Oz were the two
videotapes that the kids all like wanted
to watch every day so I saw those two
movies like
hundreds and hundreds of times because
it's like they always wanted to watch
one of those two so I was surprised that
that was the same person
but I feel like the um
so this is essentially like I said they
did change some of the stuff from the
myth but what you got is Jason who
um is kind of like he's next uh for the
throne for to thessally right but then
his uncle palius uh he wants the throne
like he kills the King which I don't
think happens in the myth I think he
just throws him in jail but uh there's a
prophecy that says oh one of the King's
kids will [ __ ] you up and like defeat
you so he's like oh well problem solved
I'm just gonna kill all the kids
um and he does like succeed in killing
some of them but then like um I guess
Jason's mom takes him to the Temple of
Hera and then like puts him in like
Hera's protection so he doesn't get
killed yeah that polias does straight up
kill that woman though just right there
in the temple just and I was like God
damn that was cold and a true Greek
fashion the Greek gods up on Olympus oh
they got the hots for the Bortles yeah
just watching hair is like picking out
[ __ ] J Jason because you know he's
hot you know [ __ ] and then like
sis doesn't give a [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
turned into a bull and having sex with
them mortal women and making demigods
and [ __ ] [ __ ] his son shows up
Hercules is in it you know can we just
talk about how how big everything
Hercules is in this movie I think like
in the in the timeline of Greek
mythology this was before Hercules like
before the trials of Hercules before it
became like Hercules so like he's still
a demigod and [ __ ] but this is like
before like all of the stuff that he did
you know what I mean so he's like one of
the ones he's one of the Argonauts he's
on Jason's crew and when they go to the
Isle of bronze which is kind of their
first stop yeah and Hera tells them
she's like now all you can take from
this island is like Provisions food and
water and that's it
and Jason says it's like you guys I'm
watching you right like don't take
anything and so they go there and then
they find like all the big huge Bronze
Statues and the one of um Talos has that
little thing underneath this has this
big treasure thing and so Hercules
straight up goes in there and steals
what the [ __ ] is that a brooch pin it
was a brooch that's right but it's for
for the Titans though so it was huge
who's gonna this is a great spear yeah
and he stole the spirit and got away
with the spirit too and the other guy
was like sitting there going it's like
um we're not opposed to do that he's
like oh they'll never miss it no one
will miss it yeah
and then he's the one that wakes up
Taylor and then he gets his friend
squished I was like the way to go herk
I'm not sure I'm not sure about the
original Greek timeline for Hercules
stories I think they were like modern
superheroes of today where they had been
rebooted many times and I'm sure people
fought over you know well that that
Hercules story is not Kane and not canon
and that's no that's fan fiction you
know uh because
Hercules [ __ ] and each Hercules story
is kind of like a standalone
uh from what I remember yeah I mean in
one of them it's just a morality tale of
Hercules turns into a woman
okay Hercules is tired of being a man
because it's too hard it is it's too
[ __ ] hard and then he turns into a
woman he's like oh wait this sucks even
more yeah yeah yeah
he goes crazy because he gives up he
gives up his manhood and gets weak and
goes crazy and tries to plow the the
ocean no plows does the uh the the uh
the seashore and he's plowing it
backwards okay and people are marveling
I don't know how [ __ ] crazy he is and
uh he finally transforms into a woman I
forgot how he transformed into a woman I
vaguely remember that gets married has
kids and raises them and does laundry
and it's like yeah washes dishes and
[ __ ]
the whole [ __ ] close yeah there's a
whole [ __ ] life as a woman the
husband dies and [ __ ] like that he's
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks he's like
[ __ ] doesn't tell me about it you
can't escape hardship I think I'd rather
be a man and he goes back becomes a man
again so so
you would say you could you we see that
today gomandis is obviously a morality
Tale but the ancient Greeks probably
consider that was to them that was a
holy story they probably thought that
actually happened or at least you know
the uneducated deal that but it's a
morality tale it's like uh don't
quit don't don't yeah don't lose your
manhood because it's [ __ ] hard it's
hard to be a woman too don't even
[ __ ] don't even try to escape it
that's yeah like I said Being a woman
probably sucks even more especially like
back then it probably would have really
sucks more yeah and then they'd go you
learn from Hercules he did it that he
didn't like
don't make the same mistake even
Hercules couldn't put up with that [ __ ]
but yeah yeah I'm gonna say like I feel
like
I've really really love this movie but I
think the thing about it is that if Ray
harryhausen hadn't done the effects I
don't know if people would still be like
talking about it today you know what I'm
saying because it's like one of the
things that's a problem like I kind of
feel like
um the best the best things about it are
like um the woman that plays Hera honor
black man like she's great and the guy
that plays Zeus and the guy that plays
Hercules even though he's a dick and he
gets like for stealing stuff after they
specifically told him not to because
Hercules cannot follow instructions
um and he gets his friend squished but
at least he has you know the um he has
the decency to like feel bad afterward
and like but he's not in the movie long
enough because he stays on the island of
Isle of bronze like after his um friend
gets squished because he's like oh I
gotta stay here and then they were like
well we're not leaving without Hercules
but then hair is like oh we got some
other [ __ ] like we got planned for him
so I guess they're like referring to
like the trials of Hercules that came
along later but the guy that played him
was like really good he was like really
entertaining I have to say the guy that
played Jason
um whose name was Todd Armstrong
um while a very handsome man I don't
know if he was all like really all that
charismatic you know what I mean did you
did you feel that which which guy again
the guy that played Jason now he's just
kind of generic that's what I'm saying
like I don't really think he was in that
many more movies if I don't if I uh
remember correctly
uh El padrino said forgive my ignorance
I never heard of this movie I'll watch
it tonight yeah it's um yeah like I said
it's kind of one of those classic uh
ones from the 60s those big like fantasy
movies and like if you're at all into
like Ray harryhauser or like stop motion
then you should totally watch it because
the stop motion that's in this is really
really good and I um I really like I
mean the skeleton Battle of course is
like epic but I really really like
um the Talos
yeah thing like where the the bronze
statue like comes to life because man
what a great [ __ ] shot that is when
Hercules and his little buddy are on the
island and Hercules steals the the
brooch pin and then like the statue like
the turns its head and they're like oh
[ __ ] like now we're traveling the [ __ ]
is the [ __ ] thing is like Giant and I
think one of the best things about that
like it's kind of like it moves like
something that was would be made of
metal and I love the sound design like
it because it makes that like that kind
of metallics like scraping noise like
when it moves it's awesome El padrino if
you if you like this one then you watch
1981 Clash of the Titans all right it's
another Greek one
and same rare array Harry housing stop
motion
um more a little more updated special
effects it was it had to now compete
with Star Wars so they even had a
mechanical owl in there boobo boobo to
compete with R2D2 yeah but that's
another good story
um
yeah that has something to do with
Perseus also talking about uh Lou
Ferrigno as Hercules yeah if you go back
even earlier to like the late 50s you
had Steve Reeves okay who was Arnold
Schwarzenegger's hero yeah he was in a
lot of those Hercules Steve Reeves is
probably most guys in the bodybuilding
scene considered Steve Reeves to
probably be the the most aesthetic man
to have ever existed
um and there's some controversy of
whether or not he used any anabolic
assistance if he was on testosterone or
any kind of steroids
he says no uh and gave a bunch of
reasons and
he shows signs of being natural and that
dude's [ __ ] physique was fantastic
you just Google it right now Steve
Reeves
he was uh he was a uh I think he was
natural and he would have been a genetic
phenomenon but he was a good actor too
and uh that's who Arnold Schwarzenegger
wanted to be
Arnold was a lot bigger but he was you
know he used assistance you know but um
a lot of good [ __ ] came out of the Greek
movie
[ __ ] thing I haven't seen a a
Hercules uh Steve Reeves Hercules in a
long time but I remember him being
pretty good I think I think Mystery
Science Theater did one or two of them
they did a lot of Hercules movies but I
don't I don't remember how many of them
were Stephen I think some of them had
Ray harryhausen and it was Steve Reeves
didn't it did wasn't there some monsters
that he fought or stop-motion oh maybe I
can't remember actually I can't remember
I think I think I think I think there
was some stop-motion in it
have to see that again
but um and then if you if you see
these two Ray harryhausen Greek flicks
you'd really like to [ __ ] Sinbad
golden voyages Sinbad seven Voyage of
Sinbad and what was it Sinbad in the eye
of the tiger I think yeah I like to ball
yeah I think we reviewed those didn't we
yeah all-star cast British casts
Tom Baker [ __ ] uh you had uh what was
that hottie from war who did the warrior
love song
um Caroline Caroline Monroe she's in
she's in one of them but this just you
know it's kind of like watching a hammer
flicks you know they're boobalicious you
know low cuts to it and [ __ ] Persian
outfits and yeah cool [ __ ] man I think I
think I like the I think I like the I
think I like the Sinbad was a little bit
better than than the um
than Jason but when you actually look at
the Jason story
Jason is the Greek
um Sinbad
they both had ships they were both doing
stuff I think they were both trying to
get a kingdom so yeah and he was just
going from place to place and having to
like fight monsters and stuff it's just
like a big fantasy Adventure right thing
where it's like you have to go to this
thing to do this and then you have to go
to the next thing it's like a quest you
know right yeah yeah and uh I would say
that they're basically the same
character just a different different
culture
yeah it's pretty much the same thing
yeah Juan Romero said the music
soundtrack for Jason is awesome yeah
this has a really good score it was
actually done by Bernard Herman who
probably most famous for doing uh psycho
but he also did seventh Voyage of Sinbad
Mysterious Island he had like a lot of
movies like that I mean he's a [ __ ] on
but yeah he did the score for this one
too and a lot of people really do like
the score for this it is very good it's
very epic
um but yeah I was trying I was thinking
about
um the Talos thing where
how how they killed him was because I'm
watching it and like Hera told him to
unscrew the little thing on his ankle
and she said look to his ankle right and
then he hit like that and then all his
like juice came out yeah
lava a bunch of lava well you know you
know what that is I looked that I looked
at um on the Wikipedia page it said what
it was and I learned something new today
and I did you know I knew quite a bit
about Greek mythology but I'd never
heard this before
um that substance that's in there it's
called what is it called ikor or icor
icker yeah so I didn't real I'd heard
that word before but I didn't realize
that it was referring to a very specific
thing okay and it's a very specific
thing it's kind of like the blood or the
substance that keeps the Titans like
alive Blood Of The Gods so yeah so
that's what it is so I was like oh I'd
heard that word before but and I kind of
knew what it meant but I didn't know
that it was that specific like the
definition okay so that's what it was
because I was like I was making the joke
it's like oh my God he's full of like
red Kool-Aid but you know what I mean
like it all came out but it seemed
really easy like because he's like all
you had to do was like unscrub like that
seems a little bit like a design flaw
but um I guess that's from the original
from the original
um myth although in the original myth
they fought Talos on the way back from
getting the Golden Fleece like not on
the way there and Medea was with them
okay and Medea Put a Spell I think on
Talos and made him take the [ __ ] out of
his own ankle and like drain his own
blood that's another thing that I'm kind
of like because I like the Medea
character in this but they really
um lessened her role in this because I
mean she did a bunch of stuff like in
the myth and in this one they didn't
really they had Jason doing some [ __ ]
that she would that she did like and
like when he was getting Madea's Thunder
yeah like when like for example like
when he was actually getting the Golden
Fleece and he was height and he was
fighting the Hydra which like I said in
the myth was a dragon he didn't kill the
dragon
um she put a spell on it and made it go
to sleep and then he went in there and
took it so she like helped him out yeah
and then they took out some other [ __ ]
she did too because the funny thing is
like he arrives there to get the Golden
Fleece
and in the movie like he's being all
sneaky but you know one of the guys that
was with him was like a mole like went
ahead and like told him it's like hey
he's coming to take your Golden Fleece
and then they're like oh you
[ __ ] you know what I mean but
like in the myth he said to the king
that he was he's like hey I'm here to
take your Golden Fleece and he's like oh
okay you can have it but you have to do
these three tasks that are like
impossible
um because he's like yeah sure if you
can do all this stuff you can totally
have it but then Jason did the tasks
anyway of course with Medea's help
because she was a sorceress so I was
like which is kind of like cheating but
we were kind of laughing because when he
gets to the island like where the Golden
Fleece is uh Medea straight up right
like seconds after meeting him pretty
much she like betrays her whole entire
uh people like to help him yeah get the
Golden Fleece and I was like man that
[ __ ] is Dick struck
she you know what I mean it's like she
barely knows that dude she's like yeah
and I'll totally like betray my whole
entire event and then run off with you
and actually in the myth I think she
actually even killed her brother
so and killed somebody else did she kill
polias maybe she did like in the myth
but she totally killed her brother too
like to help Jason escape from the
island and I'm like no dick is that
awesome come on she's like yeah you
barely did it was a Greek Golden Era you
know the big golden age that [ __ ]
were thirsty back then that's what I
said I was like oh my God and you know
and he was selected by Harris Herra
thought that she was he was hot then
[ __ ] [ __ ] mortal women thought he was
hot yeah because Hera was all yeah I
think well the thing about it too is
that I'm not saying that Herod didn't
think she was that he was hot because
she did she was like watching him all
the time
look at him go but she felt like
particularly protective of him like he
was under her protection because when he
was a baby like I said you know his mom
had put him in the you know arms of the
statue yeah to keep him from getting
murdered by polias and so she was like
oh okay well I'm gonna like protect him
uh you know for the rest of his life so
he was like favored but the one thing
another thing that is kind of like weird
about this movie is that it ends kind of
abruptly I thought it's like they just
ran out of [ __ ] to do well I think I
think I don't know if this is true like
there's something missing well I don't
know if this is true but I heard that
they were gonna make maybe like a sequel
or like another one okay because it did
kind of seem like
you know they go they get the Golden
Fleece he runs off with Medea they Mack
and like make out and then and then the
gods are just kind of like oh well that
went well it's now we're gonna we got
more Adventures planned for Jason bam
the end but then they never went back
and really claimed his kingdom you know
yeah that's what I mean they never
really like so it's it was weird because
it seemed to like end kind of abruptly
but like I said maybe because weirdly
even though this movie got like really
good
like I feel like critics really were
into it but it didn't do I don't think
it did terrible but it didn't do as well
as they were expecting it to do so maybe
they were initially thinking that it was
going to have a sequel but then it just
didn't do well enough to justify it
maybe I don't really know but yeah it
does seem to like end right away like
you don't because I was like oh okay A
lot of times Trends change the studios
just move on they're like no we don't
have time we gotta keep going yeah
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying
uh Juan says in the myth Medea ends up
killing Jason and her kids yeah that's
right
um actually in my uh in college in my
Humanities class we read uh Medea the
play by euripides and um yeah that's
that doesn't end well it doesn't end
well
you know what I mean that that whole
situation and uh yeah like I said Medea
is
I was gonna say worse in the mid like
she does more [ __ ] up [ __ ] in the myth
but in a in a lot of ways she's kind of
like sympathetic too because I think the
implication in the myth was that
she had some kind of like I don't know
if Jason had some kind of spell on her
or if there was somebody had put a spell
on her like she like super got into
Jason because it that would which would
explain like why she just like threw
over her whole entire culture and people
and everything like that like the second
he showed up and it's like yeah I'll
totally help you and like kill my people
and [ __ ] like that so you know I don't
know
um but yeah I mean
I don't know I'm trying to like think of
like the best [ __ ] from the oh and for
we forgot to talk about the other stuff
the other cool stop-motion thing which
was the harpies yeah it was like poor
that poor old blind guy on there like
yeah trying to eat like the harpies
would come and [ __ ] with him all the
time and he couldn't see him and he was
like swat at him all the time
now you understand why they call some
women harpies to this day like man
you're a harpy just somebody who just
drives so mad [ __ ] crazy flying
around stealing stealing my food
yeah and Jason Jason and his boys
[ __ ] capture when they put them all
in a cage and make him the master of the
harpies and he's back in there feeding
them that's right you listening to me
now
he was on some kind of Godly welfare
because uh he sat out there and he came
and fed him every day beautiful women
came and brought him all kinds of food
he was being punished and I was Zeus was
punishing him yeah because he um
apparently he had been given the gift of
Prophecy and he like abused it okay so
then Zeus blinded him but I guess I
don't know if they felt kind of bad and
they're like well we'll make you blind
but we'll put you out on this island it
will feed you yeah but by the way like
we'll also harpies will come every day
and like torment you and take all your
[ __ ] food yeah like while you're
trying to okay they're doing the same
thing it did the same thing to
Prometheus basically yeah yeah handing
out fire to the handing out fire to
humans yeah you're gonna pay they got
the damn eagles eating Us Down live
liver chained up to a rock that's gotta
suck yeah and it grows back
that is back every day and then it comes
that's pretty [ __ ] up I can't really
think of many things that are deserving
of that kind of Fate like especially if
it just went on forever and just don't
piss off [ __ ] Zeus man
I get but what if you do it accidentally
it seems like it'd be pretty easy to do
like maybe it's just in a bad mood that
day
um wait a minute uh El padrino said
would you one day do a review of Ron by
Akira Kurosawa oh yeah uh would love to
get your take on that one yeah actually
we should haven't seen that in a long
time I haven't either that's like a
great that's a good movie yeah I think
it was supposed to I think it was a
reboot of King Lear wouldn't it
if I remember correctly
yeah but it's a good move it's action
flick kind of like an action figure yeah
I remember it being really really good
good the good action scenes involved in
[ __ ] arrows I think that and by
looking at it they actually did shoot
arrows at that guy
arrows were coming and sticking into the
ground yeah and it looked it looked real
as someone who [ __ ] is an Archer and
I got my [ __ ] bow I'll go get that
[ __ ] and that looked like real arrows
they didn't look like they were very
powerful but
foreign
I'd have to go back and go look and see
how how strong a Japanese bow was from
that era probably pretty strong probably
50 60 pound pull at least
although I heard some people say that
some of that [ __ ] was 150 pounds I don't
know how they could hold an arrow
together at 150 pound Pole
probably just tear the tear it up
yeah you'd think yeah
they just because usually the first
thing that happens is the feathers get
ripped off
flashing
yeah
Hugo says you guys should watch Eric the
Viking 1989 with Tim Robbins it's pretty
good I remember liking that movie I saw
a lot on cable like back in the day
uh Tom Sykes said someone should do a
film about the cannibal Sonny bean and
his inbred cannibalistic family in stop
motion oh my God I would totally watch
that what is it sunny Bean we did a stop
motion Movie no no no somebody should
make a stop-motion movie about the real
case it was a family of cannibals
cannibals
that was when was that
um
[ __ ] 1800 we did a show about it a long
time ago I want to say it was 1800s was
it Scotland
all right I want to say it was Scotland
and I remember what you're talking about
now I think they put them all to the
wheel didn't it
yeah if I would spend a long time since
we did that show but yeah El padrena
said speaking of Greek mythology has
there ever been a story of Sisyphus in
film
you know I don't know I mean I'm they're
I'm sure they're had to have been I feel
like most of the Greek myths have been
made into films like at some point or
another
but
I mean I really like the idea because
they did the same thing with Clash of
the Titans I like the idea of like all
the gods just like hanging out like up
in Olympus and just like watching all
the [ __ ]
little humans like right like they're
watching reality TV and it's like now
let's [ __ ] with them let's [ __ ] with
them hey you know what I mean they did
that Clash of the Titans too they had
like all the because I thought I used to
think that was so cool when I was a kid
because in Clash of the Titans they have
like everybody on Earth apparently they
have like a little chess piece of you
yeah and they can like put you in the
little Arena and like [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] and like make you do things and
stuff yeah after you see this one you
gotta see Clash of the Titans yeah it's
like a really good it's almost like a
sequel in a way pretty much like even
though it's about like different I don't
think it's about different things it's
definitely the same universe you know
and it's definitely the same kind of
talent level I think Clash of Titans
might even had a bigger budget
yeah I think it did and I'm gonna say
like as far as it goes like Clash of the
Titans I think I like slightly better
than Jason and the Argonauts even though
I think Jason and the Argonauts
um like I really like this is the
original yeah and I really like the stop
like particularly the stop motion like
the skeleton fight and like the and
Talos and all of that I really like the
um just the set pieces that Ray
harryhausen did for that
um but I'm gonna say I think I like the
movie Clash that Titans slightly better
I think because the acting like the
actors are more charismatic yeah like um
Harry Hamlin isn't it like he's Perseus
and like I don't know I just really
really like it Ursula Andress is in it
like a lot of like really big um you
know things and I really really like
that whole end sequence with Medusa is
like super cool and I really like like
the stygian witches yeah oh Burgess
Meredith is in that [ __ ] yeah yeah so
you know what I mean so I kind of feel
like that's I mean and I'm not saying
like there's really good actors in Jason
and the Argonauts too like I said I
really really like the guy that played
Hercules I really like the um the guy
who played Zeus and like the woman that
played um Hera like those are really
good but I kind of feel like Jason and
some of the other actors were just like
a little Bland or like a little generic
so it wasn't as now I did like Medea
um I've seen that actress before I think
maybe she was on some Star Treks yeah I
think she must have been but she we were
laughing at her too because remember how
when he got to the island like how
[ __ ] thirsty she was yeah you know
when he was like fighting the Hydra like
for the fleece which like I said is
[ __ ] up because in the myth she
actually like helped but in the movie
she just like stands there and watches
but she's like standing there watching
him fight the Hydra and she looks like
she just wants to like [ __ ] hump him
yeah like yeah she's like just the look
on her face is like hilarious like when
they did so over she's like oh yeah
fight that actually she's yeah well
she's she's having like a [ __ ] she's
having a moment you know it's kind of
like she's watching a present fresetta
painting yeah male bravery and it's just
she's sucking being sucked into it you
know but uh I think I like this is a
good movie but I think I like Clash of
the Titans better yeah I think a load
better more colorful like you said more
charismatic characters better action
sequences the uh the [ __ ] was shot a
little bit better in Clash of the Titans
we're talking about 1981 Clash of the
Titans not the [ __ ] [ __ ] one that
came out in 2000 that CGI Fest no thank
you nope no character uh we're talking
about the original and um
Heron Zeus [ __ ] would come in and
steal a show [ __ ] hair bagging on
[ __ ] zoos for chasing afterwards oh
you chasing after your your little
mortal girls again he's oh no not at all
you know but it just yeah so they had
that whole thing going and oh and then
they're fighting over Perseus and she's
got a little statue of him Perseus was
his her son right or was it or was it no
it was Zeus's Zeus
with uh danai that's right the immortal
woman so he was a demigod too that's
right yeah he had gone and knocked up uh
yeah a mortal woman Hera was pissed
about it still didn't she do some [ __ ]
to try to [ __ ] him over a couple times
blew some wind on him or something and
[ __ ] his boat up I think or well she
was the one that put him remember she
put him like in she took him off the
island where he grew up and like just
stuck him in the middle of [ __ ]
that's right she's trying to make life
hard on him right because uh he was born
of another woman right I remember that
yeah and then there was like um I really
liked all the stuff in Clash of The
Titans with calabas as well like he was
super cool where he got like all and who
was she related to him that was um no
that was uh fetus the Goddess that this
that was her son and he did something
did something evil yeah he did something
like to make Hera mad I feel like maybe
what I don't remember it was Zeus her
hair like me and and uh and so I think
it was Zeus but I can't remember exactly
what he did it's been a while since I've
seen it so they so they made him look
all [ __ ] up like they made him look
like the devil kind of yeah it kind of
looked like a Seder yeah yeah yeah like
my tail and [ __ ] horns and he looked
really cool I like that whole and then
and then like he had that whole thing
where he had like the riddle yeah like
you know the riddle live uh with uh the
princess and all that kind of stuff yeah
was that the devil looking guy yeah yeah
yeah calabas yeah that was who that was
he was I think he was my favorite
character yeah and then you had the
crack in like at the end so that was
like really cool the Titans happened
because of Star Wars okay yeah and the
original Star Wars were these movies
they served the same purpose yeah you'd
be a kid in the theater and they're
taking you to a fantasy world to new
lands and you're seeing [ __ ] weird
[ __ ]
Star Wars came it's the same thing
they're taking into new planets you're
seeing new aliens you're seeing new
ships and guns
um
so they it was the same basic concept
well
[ __ ] like Jason and the Argonauts look
real tired by the time Star Wars came
out so they had to really kind of up the
game and they came out with
um Clash of the Titans
and that was around the time of like
Revenge The Return of the Jedi I think
right or uh yeah well no it would have
been Empire Strikes Back I think yeah
yeah yeah because Clash of the Titans
was 81.81 and I was watching them and I
was a kid I'd watch them side by side
enjoy them both yeah same they were just
they thought they were great so
um
yes if you're into Star Wars you'd like
the [ __ ] these old Greek movies just
look up anything that had Ray
harryhausen in it you'd like it I mean
anything like Sinbad he was just he has
never really been topped like Ray
harryhausen yeah you could tell that he
had just such affection and passion for
what he was doing and he was just such a
perfectionist like I said even nowadays
this movie came out in like 19 [ __ ]
63 and even nowadays that skeleton fight
looks amazing like it looks
they just they come out of the ground
like you know what I mean like the
[ __ ] the dude like sews the Hydra
teeth and then like the little skeletons
come out of the ground and then they all
like get into formation with their
little Shields and [ __ ] yeah harryhausen
was like the special effects guy yeah
okay for for his era so if it was going
to be a big budget [ __ ] fantasy flick
it was going to have Ray harryhausen
working on it and that's the ones you
want to see just look at whatever movie
he was in the Sinbad movies the Greek
movies and you they're good real good
and you think he did that one of the
beasts and 20 000 fathoms or something
yeah yeah that was one of his earlier
ones because I remember that one was
black and white I think he might have
done the one where about the [ __ ] the
alien that came from Venus
remember that
20 million miles to Earth or some [ __ ]
oh yeah maybe where are they [ __ ] I
can't remember enough I think that might
have been a hair that was 50s
yeah because like I said prior to this
this might have been kind of his first
big Hollywood Epic movie like the ones
he had done before have been kind of
more like I said more B movies or more
sci-fi or whatever so I think this was
kind of like his big but there's really
something about these movies from this
era
like Jason and the Argonauts and you
know like the Sinbad movies I think it's
just like I love like the Technicolor
look of them because like the color is
like super saturated and just the
costumes and the sets and [ __ ] like that
are amazing like the one the um scene
toward the end where you have uh where
he goes to Medea's like um place and
they have like that big Temple shot with
all the girls dancing and stuff like
that that looks [ __ ] great like yeah
the set design is really really awesome
too but I mean the main reason to watch
this not gonna lie is the ray
harryhausen effects I mean yeah the
acting's a little dry
it is and uh but it's a cool story and
it's worth seeing like the whole um we
forgot to mention too that whole
clashing Rock sequence like the guy with
Triton like coming out of the water and
stuff that also looks good and that's
not um that's not stop motion that was
like a guy that was like a what do they
call it a process shot right where it's
just like a two layers yeah he's holding
the mountains back and that and that
looks great too I mean for [ __ ] 1963.
they spent a lot of money on this [ __ ]
like for the time period yeah
um real good special effects for the
time Richard Brown says Wallace and
Gromit oh my God I love Wallace and
grommet like that's some [ __ ] great
uh stop motion right there
um that's Nick Nick Park Studios and
that's that's technically well
technically is that claymation because I
think they use uh plasticine or they use
that kind of like um
clay whereas I feel like
I don't know it's it's not really that
much of a difference I guess
El Patronus said did the original
Twilight Zone use claymation
I don't know yeah they had some
claymations I thought they did and
somebody mentioned the gate earlier from
1987 which also has some great
stop-motion effects in it we did a
review of that a little while back like
my favorite bit of that was like the
purse was like the dude like a human and
he falls down and then he turns into
like a bunch of little demons that were
claymation and it's like that looked
awesome that still looks awesome
I guess padrino is going to watch uh
both the Greek ones today tonight yeah
he said he'd seen Clash of the Titans
but he hadn't seen um but he hadn't seen
Jason on the Argonauts yeah Jason's good
yeah yeah and if you haven't seen
[ __ ] Sinbad movies see a ball yeah I
like all three of them yeah I like all
the Sinbad movies too all right so you
ready to wrap it up yeah we can go eat
some food all right so hope you guys are
having a good New Year's Day
and uh tomorrow we're gonna do a
haunting Mondays so I don't know what
episode we're gonna do yet I don't know
if we want to do Ghost Soldier like I
said because that one is kind of boring
so it's like so we'll have to like find
something else to watch I don't know we
might do another season seven one or we
might go back a bunch of the older
Seasons we haven't talked about that's
true some of them are good yeah maybe we
should do that because I was kind of
like the the season seven was fun but I
kind of like the older ones better all
right so uh thank you everybody for
dropping by today have a good rest of
your evening and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow bye
foreign
[Music]